quelle est l'histoire du val ibuki vie
c'est grâce aux réponses des habitants
du quartier que les fresques vont voir
le jour tout ça va nous permettre à nous
designer artiste peinte de citer
création de pouvoir penser les fresques
monumentales qu'on va écrire qu'on va
dessiner sur sur leur mur c'est à dire
leur peau et faire que justement ils
soient fiers de ce qui va être réalisée
aujourd'hui la page est blanche pour
nous donc c'est à travers ces
témoignages qu'on sera en mesure de de
pouvoir créer tout simplement la page
blanche ce sont les façades des
immeubles du vélib ou les 4000 habitants
du quartier sont mis à contribution et
les idées fourmillent déjà on voudrait
que ça retrace vingt de l'histoire va
des habitants leurs souvenirs à savoir
bandes et les moments on va dire de
joyeux puisqu'on n'a pas que des moments
joyeux dans la vie hein malheureusement
comme ça on va dire à travers des
promenades juste en regardant les murs
des bâtiments
voilà vous me donner le sourire aux
femmes de faire plein de choses paysager
'cher l'herbe les arbres des papillons
j'aimerais bien qu'il ya des couleurs
vives des fleurs des dessins des deux
armées de tout
nouveaux tricks dans un mois les
designers reviendront avec des
propositions de concepts les habitants
donneront à nouveau leur avis et les
maquettes définitifs seront présentés
début juin lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs